deep inside the greco-roman city of  Hierapolis lies the most relaxing and  the most visited site in all of Turkey  [Music]  from a distance Parma Karla's cascading  white pools seem to resemble a castle of  fluffy cotton but upon closer inspection  they reveal themselves to be solid  limestone walls housing turquoise  mineral rich water the site is fittingly  called karma carlay which translates to  cotton castles in turkish housing 17 hot  springs  they each range in temperature from 35  degrees to 100 degrees perfect for  soaking in Parma Kalle has been used as  a natural bathing spot for centuries  especially since the water in each hot  spring is filled with minerals it was  the Greek in Romans who discover that  these minerals potentially hold  countless curative properties according  to many the water brings benefits to the  skin eyes and can assist with recovery  from high blood pressure making this  cotton castle a very relaxing place to  visit  [Music]  you  [Music]